Dr house has clinic hours just like I do
so today I'm going to react to some of
his funniest and most unusual patient
encounters also huge thank you to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
so where do you feel the pain
get in the back of my head here it's
picarious sign finally down by your
third trimester I'm not in school
neither is your fetus
oh God you didn't know you were pregnant
how do you you know that just from my
headache I know because of the tight
shirts stretched over the swollen boobs
the salt craving you reported into the
clinic the motion sickness patch he's
like an Amazon algorithm that knows what
you purchased so he thinks he knows you
it's like how Tick Tock has been
pointing out things about us because it
knows us so well because of what we
watch and what we search and what we
click Dr house was the original
algorithm I'm a virgin
so is my fiance
I believe him aren't there other ways I
could get pregnant like
sitting on a toilet seat absolutely
there we need to be a guy sitting
between you and the toilet seat but yes
absolutely
oh that was a good line I'm waiting here
for six hours
am I a father or not
no
she also didn't cheat on you normally
sperm eats egg DNA meets DNA goes back
to her place sells divide nine months
later Joy is bundled abnormally an egg
could have two naturally occurring gene
mutations that don't naturally occur
together spontaneous calcium Spike could
prep the egg for fertilization without
sperm in a division in the state you
could let the egg split up without ever
needing male DNA at all Jesus I've never
heard of this the humans it's only ever
been theorized it was never proved
well obviously on house it's going to
happen your daughter as only maternal
DNA I personally check this five times
in seven months you will have a virgin
birth
Merry Christmas
I I can't I there's no way this has ever
been reported let's cry
who cares it's beautiful what was he
looking on we're half as well maintained
as that pigeons wouldn't have the nerve
to poop on it looking into the nose with
an auto skull you're not going to get a
lot of information usually you have to
go deeper with a fiber optic camera
which is like one of those cameras that
you go in with a remote and you could
see it on a video screen that's where
you're gonna get good info you can
really visualize the turbulence the
posterior nasal passageways you can even
see the vocal cords once you go a little
further down good grooming is important
is that a shot
people who judge you on your appearance
When you entered I noted your shirt
hadn't been pressed you hadn't shaved in
quite some time I extrapolated you are a
person for whom detail was not a major
concern I like that he's pointing it
correctly most people point it up but if
you're pointing it up you're just
looking at the front of the nose so he
is pointing in the correct direction at
least I was worried you might apply that
same standard in you can use toenail
clippers up there whoa don't use toenail
covers in your nose folks they're longer
so they allow me to better reach the
other hairs bro get one of those tools
that you go in you press the button and
it just has like a protected little
shaver in there you've got athlete's
foot in your nose oh so he basically has
a tinia a fungal infection in his nose
probably because his nail clipper had
toenail fungus but house would not have
been able to know that without a looking
at his toe and confirming that he has an
onico mycosis which is a toenail fungus
and B that this is in fact fungal spores
a fungal rash especially in an enclosed
environment like this it's just going to
look like irritating on a mucous
membrane you're not going to know
exactly what's the cause sore throat
oh that's a lot of blood maybe close the
curtains there champ and give the
patient some privacy
stop lupus well not everyone can operate
a zipper of the up down he's sweating a
lot so he's either going into shock he
has an infection a fever something's
going on my new girlfriend
never been with a guy who wasn't
circumcised
so she freak he tried to circumcise
himself
foreign
I got some box cutters and uh box cutter
Abraham did it they sterilized them
I'm gonna get a plastic surgeon
you can keep back in the rubber that's
probably the most real part of house
that you get a plastic surgeon or you
get a specialist involved because Dr
House can't be a specialist for
everything let's take a moment and talk
about ship station the leading web-based
order management and shipping software
it's designed to make retailers lives
Easier by making processing fulfilling
and shipping e-commerce orders more
efficient it's a new year and with that
comes a lot of headaches as you navigate
post-holiday business such as late
orders or returns I sell my own merch
and believe me shipstation can make your
shipping process so much easier thanks
to them you can focus on growing your
business from day one as they eliminate
the headaches that come with printing
labels or handling orders across
multiple platforms like Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify and more they've had
the best rates in the game for a while
too but they just got even better
because now you can get up to 86 off of
USPS and UPS rates when you use ship
station thanks to them over a hundred
thirty thousand companies have grown
their e-commerce business and 98 of
those companies that use them for one
year become customers for life make the
New Year your best year and grow your
business with chipstation go to
shipstation.com Dr Mike remember doctor
is spelled out and sign up for a free
60-day trial all right let's get back to
the show the top of my head's killing me
you spent a week doing top of head in
anatomy I know just where it is
oh
oh my God how did he know those okay if
someone says the top of their head is
hurting them and then you push on the
sinuses and the sinuses are tender
that's interesting your sinuses are
clogged judging where the scratches on
your hands I'm guessing a new cat
that was my mother's
there's Dad
no yeah so if you have an allergic
reaction to a cat that can cause
obviously congestion in your nasal
passageways it can cause your eustachian
tube which is the pressure relieving
tube inside the the sinuses and ear
canal to get inflamed close up because
it's a very short not short very narrow
tube and when it gets inflamed it closes
off and it feels like there's a lot of
pressure in here and a lot of people
want antibiotics for their sinus
infections whereas most sinus infections
are caused by a viral cause not
bacterial therefore you don't need
antibiotics you have to knock off an
hour early today now why
because I kiss my boss's ass you ever do
that
I think she just said yes because she
wants to reinforce that behavior wants
me to kiss a lot of other people's ass
like she wants me to kiss yours what
would you want a Doctor Who holds your
hand while you die or a doctor who
ignores you while you get better I guess
it would particularly suck to have a
doctor who ignores you while you die
I should go I think it's gonna come out
on its own I I just do not understand
his diagnosing ability he has ultrasound
vision he's like a dolphin but a doctor
dolphin you can make the echo of the
sound bounce off his intestinal walls
and tell him that there's something in
his butt how did you you've been here
half an hour you haven't sat down that
tells me his location or he's nervous
you haven't told me what it is that
tells me it's humiliating I have a
little birdie carved under your arm and
tells me you have a high tolerance for
humiliation so I figured it's not
Emerald I've been a doctor 20 years
you're not going to surprise me
it's an MP3 player an iPod what are we
gonna do
I'm gonna wait
maybe ask maybe do some Imaging maybe
see if there's an obstruction my guy
small bowel obstructions happen usually
because of a post-surgical adhesion but
here too he's been using his inhaler not
in the past few days he's um only 10 I
worry about children taking such strong
medicine so frequently
what happened to your leg the doctor
probably was concerned about the
strength of the medicine too she
probably weighed that danger against the
danger of not breathing yeah so for a
child with asthma I see parents run into
this issue quite often a lot of times
have concerns about using a preventive
inhale of which you're supposed to use
every single day and you're not supposed
to use these willy-nilly the way that we
treat asthma is a step up plan so we
start with the lowest amount of
intervention and then we work our way up
depending on the symptoms depending on
the severity of the illness and
sometimes you need to take a preventive
in order to decrease the amount of times
you need to use your emergency inhaler
to decrease the amount of times you have
nighttime attacks and most importantly
to decrease the amount of times you end
up in a hospital intubated that's why we
do it and something interesting about
asthma is if you're having an acute
asthma attack and you're in a hospital
you're breathing really fast and you're
trying to breathe out it's really
important to know that if you just start
fatiguing and breathing slower even
though you haven't improved your
wheezing that could be a sign that
you're fatiguing and that's a reason you
need to get into beta to actually buy
you time in order for the as of attack
to pass where does House MD rank on my
master list of best medical dramas click
here to find out and don't forget to
visit shipstation.com Dr Mike to begin
your 60-day free trial as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]